الامريكي بزيارة تستمر اربعة
ايام لليابان وتترأس وفدا رئاسيا
الاراضي الاوكرانية تشغل العالم
لكن ماذا عن بقية الاراضي التي
وذكرت الوكالة ان الملياردير
الروسي رومان ابراموفيتش كان هو
لامدادات الطاقة الروسية. وصفقة
الغاز تلوح في الافق بين المانيا
الروسي الذي التقى بالامير
السعودي سرا فعندما المصالح
الوقود. بعدما الغيت المقابلة
التليفزيونية لرفضها مكشوفة
وافادت وكالة يونهب للانباء ان
الجيش الكوري رصد مؤشرات على ان
في الخليج. وجولة للمستشار
الالماني وملف الطاقة ياتي على
ولكن على طريقة كيم جونج اون.
الاحداث والتطورات. ارتفع عدد
الفلسطيني في تحقيق السلام اخذة
بالتراجع مشددا على ان اسرائيل
كتيبة اسرائيلية وصورا لشهداء
اطفال غزة وطالب الامم المتحدة
بانها في نيويورك ولا يوجد هناك
قوانين ولا تقاليد تخص تغطية
لقوا حتفهم من طالبي اللجوء في
غرق قارب قبالة سواحل طرطوس
الخليج. لقد سبقه بايدن. وطرق
ابواب الخليج فلم يرأف به احد
يستطيع مقارعة اصحاب العيون
الضيقة. اوروبا تطرق ابواب
كوريا الشمالية ربما تستعد
لاختبار صاروخ باليستي تطلقه
تبدأ تنفيذ خطة للانتقال الى
الطاقة المتجددة مع ارتفاع اسعار
لا تؤمن بالسلام. عباس ايضا رفع
صورة طفل فلسطيني مقاتل مقابل
الرأس لتلغى بعدها هذه المقابلة
ولكن لم نعلم هل هي المذيعة التي
ان سياسات اسرائيل دمرت اتفاقية
اوسلو وقوضت فرص حل الدولتين.
الذي نجح في صفقة تبادل الاسرى
حيث كشفت وكالة بلومبرج عن
الرأس مذيعة سي ان ان كريستيانو
منفو ترد على الرئيس الايراني
لحضور جنازة رئيس الوزراء
الياباني السابق شينزو ابي.
الاماكن الدينية وامريكا تحميها.
ومئات القرارات الامم المتحدة
اجتماعهما الوصول للاتفاق المهم
مؤخرا بين روسيا واوكرانيا.
بحرية في العالم. فمهما دعمت
واشنطن تايوان بالاسلحة بكين
استقلال تايوان كلما قل احتمال
التوصل الى تسوية سلمية حسب
السعودي دورا مهما في العقود
المقبلة. هذا الامير السعودي هو
السورية الى ستة وثمانين شخصا
كانوا على متن القارب واعلنت
وزارة النقل السورية ان عمليات
البحث عن ناجين مستمرة. فرنسا
الصينية في بيان بشأن الاجتماع
ان الولايات المتحدة ترسل اشارات
رأس اولويات الزيارة. فدول
اوروبا تبحث عن ايجاد بدائل
المرتقب بين برلين وابو ظبي?
ويتحدث الالمان ان ولي العهد
تقصف والشعب العراقي بين مقصلة
المالكي وسندان الصدر فالى متى
ستتفوق عليها بالعدد اولا ثم
بالعتاد ثانيا. فضلا عن الحرب
الشخصية التي التقاها الامير
محمد بن سلمان وكان نتاج
بوضع خطة لانهاء الاحتلال واضاف
اسرائيل تواصل الاعتداء على
والامارات. فهل ينقذ غاز
الامارات المانيا في الاتفاق
وخلال كلمته امام الجمعية العامة
للامم المتحدة قال عباس ان ثقة
الغتها ام الرئيس الايراني الحرس
الثوري الايراني يقصف بالمدفعية
بالاسلحة لصد اي هجوم محتمل
للجيش الصيني على الجزيرة لكن
الخاصة بفلسطين لم ينفذ واحد
منها. فهل يجدي استعطاف الرئيس
خاطئة وخطيرة للغاية بشأن
تايوان. وانه كلما زاد نشاط
سيتحمل جسد العراق كل هذه
الطعنات استفتاءات روسيا لضم بعض
وصفها. مع ذلك فان الولايات
المتحدة تركز على دعم تايوان
الالكترونية حيث ستتفوق الصين
بدون شك. ولهذا بدأت الولايات
مواقع في كردستان العراق. امريكا
تقصف العراق وايران تقصف وتركيا
الاعلان عن التعبئة الجزئية. اي
رسالة يريد الروس ايصالها للغرب
الفلسطيني يا ترى? استقبال
المجنون. تقوم نائبة الرئيس
وعاد بخفي حنين. لتذهب بعده
المانيا وتطرق نفس الباب من
بين وزيري الخارجية الصيني
والامريكي. لكنها لا تخفي حدة
يا ترى? الرد الاوروبي. قال
المفوض الاعلى للسياسة الخارجية
الدفاع عن نفسها. لكن ماذا ان
توقفت الاستفتاءات? هل سيتوقف
للاحتفال بزيارة كاميل هاريس
نائبة الرئيس الامريكي للمنطقة
غواصة وقد يكون تجربة نووية وذلك
كترحيب خاص من بيونج يانج
غير مدرب الى المعركة بين ليلة
وضحاها ولا يمكن اختصار مهلة
مرضية. الجرح العربي ينزف. اكد
الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس على
المواطنون الى نقطة استقبال
افراد الوحدة العسكرية في بعد
الروسية ونفاذ للتذاكر. هناك
ازدحام اخر للتجنيد حيث توافد
وكأن الروس لا يأبهون بتهديدات
الغرب وتحالفاتهم. الصين تتصافح
الدعم عندها? الرد جاء من
الكرملين. الذي قال ان روسيا
منذ بداية الحرب ومهلة التعبئة
غير كافية ولا يمكن ارسال جندي
اوكرانيا. واضاف الاتحاد
الاوروبي سيرد على الاستفتاءات
التجارية والمطالب السياسية
بطاولة واحدة تكون النتائج دائما
معظم الاسلحة تكون لصد اي هجوم
برمائي ولدفن اسلحة الصين بين
الاوكرانية لاستعادة تلك المناطق
باعتبارها هجوما على اراض روسية
البريطانية ان التعبئة الجزئية
في روسيا لن تكون سهلة التطبيق.
فاستدعاء ثلاثمائة الف جندي هو
عدد كبير مقارنة بمائتين وعشرين
الحرب وان اوروبا لن تعترف
بالاستفتاءات في دومبس وخرسون في
وزارة الخارجية الاوكرانية في
بيان ردا على فعل عدائي الى هذا
اسقاط طائرات ايرانية الصنع
لكنها لم تكتفي بذلك. حيث قالت
ومحوره دائما قضية تايوان. من
جانبها ذكرت وزارة الخارجية
سفارة طهران في كييف. تصريحات
استخباراتية. قالت الاستخبارات
ستتجاوب سريعا مع نتائج
استفتاءات الانضمام اذا ما جاءت
جديد. فهل تعود بما يدفئ شتاءها
الذي اعده بوتين? اوروبا تتسول
بمواصلة تقديم الدعم العسكري
لاوكرانيا من اجل تمكينها من
مع واشنطن. وزير خارجية الصين.
من يفتعل حربا بالوكالة سيحترق
والامن في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزي
بوريل ان الرئيس الروسي سيخسر
المتحدة في استقطاب مواهب الامن
السيبراني لتكوين جيش لربما
الحد قرر الجانب الاوكراني ان
يحرم سفير ايران في اوكرانيا
مياه البحر ورماله. تخفي الصين
ما هو اعظم. فهي تمتلك اكبر قوة
بها. لتعلو بعد هذا التصريح
اصوات الضحك الدعابات ومصافحة
التوترات بين واشنطن وبكين وعلى
مدى تسعين دقيقة ظل الحوار.
اوراق اعتماده ويقلص بشكل ملحوظ
عدد افراد الطاقم الدبلوماسي في
مسيرة ايرانية واسفرت عن قتيل
واحد. بعد ذلك اعلنت اوكرانيا عن
الاخيرة ايجابية. وحذر الكرملين
ان روسيا ستتعامل مع اي
العالمية الثانية وايد خطة لضم
مساحات شاسعة من اوكرانيا واثار
احد يعلم سبب هذا التغيير.
فلماذا قمت بذلك يا بوت اوكرانيا
الثلاثة اشهر. وبينما هناك فرار
من التجنيد وازدحام في المطارات
مسؤولا عن الخدمات اللوجستية
للقوات المسلحة الروسية. لكن لا
على نحو صريح احتمال نشوب صراع
نووي. خلال ذلك قالت وسائل اعلام
ملابسها ولا نظارتها القديمة
فشيطانة الاقتصاد الروسي ما
مع ذلك فقد كان بوتين قد امر
باول تعبئة في روسيا منذ الحرب
تعاقب ايران. تعرض ميناء اوديسا
لضربة روسية استخدمت فيها طائرات
كارين جامبيير ناخذ هذه
التهديدات بوضوح على محمل الجد
اوكرانية. واضاف ان واشنطن لن
تعترف ابدا بضم اي اراض اوكرانية
روسية انه تم اعفاء الجنرال من
منصبه في حين تم تعيين رئيس
لصواريخ العقوبات الغربية. لترد
المتحدثة باسم البيت الابيض
بيولينا هي سلاح الردع الاقتصادي
لروسيا الذي يتصدى بها بوتين
لا تنسى ان بوتين يمتلك سلاح
الردع الاقتصادي. فلا تغرنكم
لروسيا. لكن ماذا ان لم تعترف
بها يا بايدن? ما سيحدث? هل نحن
يستقبل نائبة الرئيس الامريكي
خلال زيارتها الجارة الجنوبية.
الصين بالتراضي مع موسكو؟ اوروبا
تدخل في مرحلة التسول النفطي
والخليج اول اهدافها؟ عن فلسطين
في مجد الامن نسمع جعجعة ولا نرى
بكين تحت طاولتها السياسية؟ هل
هي الخيانة؟ ام انها لعبة تلعبها
المركز الوطني للرقابة الدفاعية
لروسيا ميخائيل بدلا عنها ليكون
لكننا لا نرى اي مبرر لتغيير
وضعنا النووي في هذا الوقت لكن
بصدد مواجهة بين واشنطن وموسكو
ام انها تصريحات عابرة? يا رجل
اجراءات اقتصادية اضافية سريعة
وحازمة ضد روسيا اذا ضمت اراضي
نعم جو بايدن في بيان رسمي قائلا
سنعمل مع حلفائنا وشركائنا لفرض
الاستفتاءات بهذا الاجراء؟
مصافحة وضحكات ونقاش مؤدب. لماذا
طحينا والمجنون اه. اقصد رئيس
كوريا الشمالية كيم جونغ اون
وعلامات الغضب تملأ تعبير وجهه
وكانه يقول لقد نفذ رصيد الصبر.
الصبر الامريكي بدأ ينفذ. الرئيس
الامريكي يظهر امام الجميع
كل هذه المجاملات يا اصحاب
العيون الضيقة؟ ما الذي تخبئه
وجه اوروبا. ليظهر هذا الفارس
العجوز متحديا ومتوعدا. الزعيم
الروسي يعفي جنرالا ويعين اخر في
جيشه. فما القصة؟ وطائرات ايران
ها هو بوتين يفي بوعده. فهل هناك
من مبارز؟ هكذا قالت روسيا في
تضرب في اوكرانيا. فبما سترد
كييف الاتحاد الاوروبي. سنرد على
تدور فيها الحرب هل تم نسيانها?